[Music]
what is that thing called when
you are motivated to prove someone wrong
revenge stubbornness um maybe stubborn
i don't prove someone wrong yeah
whatever that is that's kind of
vengeful right a little bit revenge
revenge right yeah what's the difference
between revenge and vengeance
same thing that's what you're seeking
for seeking vengeance seeking vengeance
with revenge
yeah yeah okay anyway so this woman
she molded proving someone wrong moded
yeah so she moded a tarik
card reader you can't just say moto
though you got to be like moldy
exposed you don't use it in a sentence
you just like happens after the fact
hey bro you got motives you gotta be the
hype man
you can never really like be the primary
so you're so knowledgeable anthony
so this woman she won the first
prize in a lottery of 100 000
and she says like she was just so
excited so happy because she had never
won anything
in her whole life oh and by the way she
also won
a a this other prize of two thousand
dollars which
equates it to a hundred and two thousand
dollars i've actually never won anything
in her
way yeah so she won twice and this one
thing okay
so she did one t thing's got it yeah she
wants you molded one
[Laughter]
but yeah so then she says a tarot card
reader
read my cards years ago and told me i
would never win
anything in my life since then i have
been trying my best
to prove her wrong now i can say i have
this person's a loser
damn she spent her entire life trying to
prove a psychic wrong she's a winner
all right all right i was again i tried
to set myself up yeah
this is a dangerous article she is a
winner and it was in her whole life it
was just a couple years
or like whatever years
you know if it was like scott from third
grade it's like man [ __ ] that you guys
would just say because in my school
uh we would be like you got moted like
it was like a whole sentence
yeah with the shoulder and like next
time
but the hand gesture was the same i've
heard both of them
and it doesn't feel good when they say
that to you you know what else doesn't
feel good
i'm telling oh oh
it makes you want to beat their ass yeah
you feel like you're
you're like whole like your heart just
sinks to your stomach
you know what it sucks too is when
you're like playing and [ __ ]
and then you kind of leave out the
little brother or sister and then they
tell on you and then they come back with
the mom and they're like
mom says you have to play with me yeah
and i'm like oh we gotta [ __ ] bring
them in the groove [ __ ]
damn i couldn't even let it happen
organically
and then he's looking at you holding
hands
okay i a picture of you having that face
that look as as a little kid just
holding my teddy bear
but isn't it embarrassing that you have
to force people to play with you i
always thought i was a little kid
i was like oh my god you oh well fine
i'll play with you
but not if you don't make eye contact
you know what i mean it's like your
mom's talking you're like
oh true you know what i mean yeah then
it's like now you gotta play with me
dude i always like i didn't want to but
you know my mom said so i always felt
really good when that
kid that was like the tattletail kid
when they'd be like i'm gonna go
tell and then they go tell the grown up
and they're so sick and tired of this
[ __ ] kid always
bothering them that the girl was like
okay okay okay and i'm like
nothing happened i'm gonna be like that
dad like yo
you should never rat out your friends is
this your friend no let's go beat his
ass
what if though this fortune teller saw
it
and she's like but the only way to get
her to do this she's a lazy ass [ __ ]
that's right so i'm gonna make her feel
like she needs to challenge herself like
morpheus morpheus
the oracle lady told neo what he needed
to hear
to do the right thing instead of
actually telling him his future she was
the oracle
that's why she's like joke's on you she
goes actually joke's on you i knew this
that's so selfless she's like she
reversed it again and she's like
oh well [ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm gonna lose
that i'm gonna lose everything
yeah so she pulls the card right and the
card's like this person's a winner but
they won't be a winner if you tell them
what this card is
oh [ __ ] oh i have a choice right now
she's like doing her so she goes like
this she goes
moody
and then she comes back in your face
fortune [ __ ]
you didn't even tell my fortune right
and she's like actually she pulled it
from like a little chest
q is your actual car i know
have you guys ever gotten your cards red
yeah chinese style
nope i don't play with black magic did
you heard a thing come true
the last card i got so here's the thing
actually uh very last time i did a
reading i just pulled a card from
my friend who did a read for me and i
got the death card
right but the thing is the death card
yeah the death card isn't like
about you dying it's actually it's like
this skull with flowers in it drawn into
in terms of the picture
and then when you read like the
description it's usually about
like acknowledging something that or
some sort of dead weight that you have
to get rid of in your life so you have
to kind of like
release yeah you have to let go of
something that is harmful heavy weighted
or damaging
uh and it's considered dead weight so
that's what like the death is it's
supposed to be more of like a phoenix
rising from the ashes experience
versus like a you about to die son so
it's a good card but it's
of course shadowed in like a veil of
something that is fearful
so it's kind of like reading or like
interpreting your dreams
it's like something that's there that
now this is being revealed to you
to me tarot cards are similar to like
astrology and like fortune cookies right
like if it applies to you in that moment
or you want it to you're going to figure
out in your brain you're going to
connect the way that you receive it to
something that makes sense or is
applicable confirmation bias
exactly but that's helpful though
because it's just like energy right it's
like if you
if you put that attitude or the energy
out that you want something that kind of
action if you will um you're more likely
to experience that type of experience
you get the confidence of that sugar
pill
yeah but what if it's bad though it's
like like what this lady got you'll
never win
anything in your life and then you have
that confirmation by yourself see i knew
i was going to be a loser
but then this lady she refused to
believe in the fortune
maybe she she oracled her ass
and she felt from her personality like
this is the push she needs
yeah what if she spent like millions of
dollars just entering all these sweets i
know right now
that's why i want a hundred thousand she
goes see i told you you are a loser
losers she wins the amount you lost 900
000 but you won 100 000.
and on top of that this tarot card
reader could technically just read the
same reading to everybody that comes
through
so 99 out of 100 of them are actual
losers and one person wins you know what
i'm saying it's like the
the homer simpson one with the fortune
cookies
never remember that no no okay so he's
like he gets his fortune after he gets
like the poison eats like the poison
blow up fish or something at the
japanese restaurant so he's about to die
oh that episode's mad racist now
for today's standards yeah yeah when is
simpson not going to be racist but
they're all yellow by the way um right
it's like oh no it's like you're about
to die but then it goes
to the cut scene where the guy's like oh
we're out of the euro the bad luck
fortune should we open the good luck
fortunes now
and it's just like this whole you know
how you receive stuff but
i really believe in that not necessarily
believing like
i do believe in the universe's magic too
but you know not not like i don't i
don't say look at a tarot card i'm like
oh my god this is for real my future
but i feel like those moments are like
uh their nudges
in the direction of your destiny if you
like choose to allow it but that's why i
don't [ __ ] with it because i don't want
anyone to poison my mind with their
suggestions that's how i feel about it
because
like it's like even if i don't believe
that it's real what can happen
is shift your focus so you might have
um like for example right like if you
believe in
like constantly thinking of something
you can manifest it because it's always
at the forefront of your mind
let's say you play one day go let's go
watch [ __ ] look at [ __ ] tarot
cards right then you your mind is
already on um
let's say business or something else and
then during the terror call thing it
tells you
uh you will be a [ __ ] traveling
sailing hippie
and you're like oh really what the hell
and you keep thinking about it and
thinking about and thinking about it and
then your focus gets shifted
from business to that and then you're
just traveling the world
riding a sailboat and it sounds fun but
at the same time that's not what you
wanted
they implanted that idea maybe though
that is paralleled with something that
you wanted because you went to go see
the tarot card read in the first place
not like they cold called your ass
you were looking for something you're
looking for change maybe an infomercial
yeah i know and clearly i'll tell you
all the [ __ ] all cleo
i have gotten my cards uh like what is
it written
palms red red okay red
once and um that was when i was
18 eight something like that and this is
actually before isaac so nevermind i was
like 16 17.
anyway so when i went there she was
telling me all these things and i'm like
well first of all i didn't go there i my
friend wanted to go there so then i just
your friend uh
bifini yeah sure bethany so she wanted
to go
because we were driving by she was like
oh look i want to stop by really quick
and i'm like okay sure whatever one of
those small places was the tiny ass
house in the middle of a parking lot
yeah something like that with a little
neon sign like really
it's like a hand yeah really really
random i forgot what were we doing that
day but the point is
she wanted to go and i'm so against it
too i'm just like
listen i don't want to [ __ ] mess with
that i actually have a similar
mentality about it too where i'm like i
don't want them to tell me some [ __ ] and
then now i'm going to think about it and
it's going to
impress me me neither i don't want to do
that but then um
and then all also i was like really like
extra superstitious back then so i'm
like i don't want like the devil to
follow me or demons
just by entering this place but i guess
obviously i wasn't that hard on my my
ideas because i ended up
like after she got her [ __ ] read she was
like come on like she's she's gonna do
it for free like you know because
you've never done it before like you
want to do it and i was just like okay
fine and the whole time i was just like
this is stupid it's [ __ ] like just
[ __ ] whatever so then she was like
telling me all these things
and then like the one of the last things
she said was like oh you know what like
in your love life
uh your the third love of your life
is gonna be the one you marry and then
i'm like okay
sure whatever and he's gonna be asian no
and then so
number three all right everything three
five and so then that at that time i i
was
with isaac's dad and then years later we
break up and then i get with another
dude are you counting at that time we're
like number one
number 15. she's like i like number two
but i'm supposed to ditch him
no so you never loved anyone before that
no
no
and then so like those were what if they
had a threesome
two and three at the same time do you
marry both of them but it's not about
sex it's about love
what if you threesome love them at the
same time
so then uh well after like bringing up
with that dude and then we started
dating and then there was this one like
i threw a halloween party at my place
and that's when like i had invited him
he got to meet all my friends
and during that time i got so [ __ ]
drunk
and for some reason i started telling
you about that tarot card reader
what did i say do you remember you told
me like uh yeah like like that
the your tarot card reader was telling
you that the third
love of your life will be the third the
third
the oh the third one two three
third of your uh their love of your life
would be the one you'd marry yeah
and then what did i was like you believe
that and you're like
maybe and i was like well i don't
believe it
if it didn't dig down i was like
interesting
but did you ask me because like i was so
drunk i really don't remember the exact
conversation but i think you did ask me
something like
like oh so like am i number three or
something like that
i think i you asked me something like
that he's fact-checking he's like where
is this tarot card person what's her
history
yeah and then so but i remember you
feeling
like a little bit freaked out that i
told you this because
you were just like it was our first race
big shoes to fill
yeah it's like [ __ ] like our destiny's
been written already damn like
i'm just trying to go on a date first
yeah well it was like our first like
heart to heart too
like like a real that's nice
that vulnerable can't even remember
don't you feel like i was so drunk
because we started dating in may this is
already in october so we had all that
time of dating
for such a clearly positive and
influential hopefully
element into your life to have been true
don't you feel like you owe it to
yourself
and to this tarot card reader to like go
back either say thank you or just be
like what's next
no i don't want to mess with it at all
yeah but that's what you said the first
time
exactly i don't want to mess with it and
it came true
you messed with it yeah that's why i'm
like well not anymore
and then she's like no no come on it's
free it's your second time nope
nope neva hello guys thank you guys so
much for watching all of our videos and
i know it's been a million years in the
making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yup so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you bye-bye
you